it's time for our scene in unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to fox news contributor raymond arroyo
ray now mayors across the country have
begun to reinstate
our favorite mask mandates for their
citizens
but i guess the rules don't really apply
to the mayors
apparently not laura the day dc mayor
muriel bowser
issued her mask mandate she partied with
dave chappelle
with no mask then on saturday the day
the masked man date went into effect
she officiated a wedding with no mask
and
bowser was photographed indoors at the
wedding dinner again with
no mask so read into that what you'd
like
now in a statement her office said she
was actively eating
or drinking raymond oh come on does it
look like she's eating or in any way
drinking in this shot
no one in the shot even has a flute or a
fork in their hands she was just
ignoring her own mass guidance and not
wanting to the rule to impinge on her
social life
by the way she attended a party with
dave chappelle sunday night
at the kennedy center as well no report
yet on whether she had a mask on
our mayor here in new orleans latoya
cantrell your favorite
she dropped a mask mandate on the city
friday but just a few hours before she
attended a luncheon
at a french quarter restaurant without a
mask
the mayor even took pictures with diners
laura she wore
they wore masks but she didn't she left
it off for wolf blitzer too
even in the state of louisiana i'm the
first in the state to push for
a mass mandate it shouldn't be
people are dying children are dying well
according to the times picayune laura
exactly nine children have died in the
state of louisiana from covid since it
began
our children are dying all right but in
the streets it's gunfire taking them out
five people were shot on bourbon street
it looked like a crazed uh
wilding in the street sunday morning and
a juvenile was gunned down and killed
nearby
that's the pandemic that this mayor
needs to address and all these mayors
they need to to begin to implement and
display
what they're trying to force their
citizenry to adopt
but raymond role models yeah we've been
on this since
march and april of 2020 when they rolled
out all the perpetual crisis measures
and they were going up to look at their
boats and they're going families going
to florida
and everyone else supposed to stay
inside and just you know suck their
thumbs i mean it's just
it's so obvious from the beginning all
right what else right
well look we've been covering hunter
biden art sale laura for weeks i even
went down to that gallery well
government ethicists say the sky high
prices and scant oversight of this art
sale
it's a tempting target for those looking
to buy
influence with the biden administration
well now biden hunter biden
has reacted this way
what's your response to the people who
are you know coming after like the
prices of the work or
other than criticism of sharing your art
to a wider audience than your friends
and family
is uh it's a pretty courageous thing to
do
laura it is courageous it is very look
when you're facing federal investigation
for failing to pay taxes on your foreign
business dealings
it's courageous to set up an influence
pedaling operation
at a gallery with ties to china that is
courageous i i have to say
hunter i like the circle painting that
look like the toilet paper holders
stamped on them
i love that but um i can only pay 350k
for it all right man so
what can you do for me all right well
look it takes real courage to blow spit
and ink through a pipe and
call it hard that's courage raymond
there's a u.s
olympic shot putter raven saunders was
what was that big uh crossing the arms x
sign at the end of that medal ceremony
uh the other day what was that all about
well the u.s olympic
said she like broke no rules by doing
this protest or did
she or not right well look the americans
are trying to stretch the rules here the
olympic committee
restricted protest laura to before an
event
but forbade them during medal ceremonies
well team usa
says saunders did this gesture during
the time
reserved for pictures after the medals
were awarded but she's on the podium
the international committee is still
looking
into sanctioning saunders they have to
enforce these rules laura
or otherwise these games are going to
turn into constant rolling
protest ceremonies that's not what
people want yeah well i thought she was
stretching
you know when i do my orange theory i
stretch like that
so um i didn't i didn't understand
i don't know the rules are the rules but
you know they're looking for little
loopholes but i think it wrecks the
games it's just we
you know we're there to watch the
athleticism which is impressive but
that's not
raymond thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else